peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les athlètes américains n'oublie pas que
1960 et l'année olympique
en attendant cet événement dans toutes
les disciplines sportives les champions
américains mettent les bouchées doubles
c'est le cas des gymnastes notamment qui
met au point avec beaucoup d'application
tous les exercices classiques de cette
spécialité il est vrai qu'ils auront
fort à faire contre les soviétiques que
cet été à rome
[Musique]
attention pas pts et c'est peut-être
cela qu'on appelle le mouvement
perpétuel
[Musique]
plus sérieux encore et l'entraînement
des athlètes américains ici le 200 m
qu'elle participerait au nord comme l'un
des tous premiers favoris de la finale
olympique
norton déboule dans la dernière ligne
droite vingt secondes 6/10 record du
monde et galets pour monsieur fils de
faire c'est à dire john tamas un record
du monde c'est une simple formalité
et voilà john thomas s'affranchit de
mettre 17 sens mais leur sort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
achevant son voyage au nouveau monde le
président de la république a retrouvé la
france en guyane et aux antilles à
cayenne d'abord à fort de france ensuite
au milieu d'une foule martiniquaise
débordant à la guadeloupe enfin le
général de gaulle a donné l'assurance
que le gouvernement n'oubliez pas les
lointains départements d'outre-mer
à paris pour son premier dimanche dans
la capitale le chef de l'état devait
recevoir un visiteur de marque
monsieur neo
le premier ministre de l'inde était venu
en voisin de londres où se tenait la
conférence du commonwealth les deux
hommes d'état devait avoir d'importants
entretien
ce même jour la france célébrait
l'anniversaire de la victoire et le
président de la république s'était rendu
à l'arc de triomphe de l'étoile pour s'y
recueillir sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu 8 mai 1945
quinze ans après le premier artisan
français de cette victoire a été le
premier à la commémorer
[Musique]
à deauville s'est tenu le congrès de la
fédération nationale de la presse
à l'ordre du jour les problèmes
d'actualité qui se posent à 2000
journaux et organes hiver mais aussi la
question de la liberté d'opinion sujet
que les 250 délégués ont exposé à leurs
invités monsieur terrenoire ministre de
l'information
le tout bon à l'heure de l'indépendance
cette indépendance monsieur sylvanus
olympio emprunt taxe devant le
représentant de la france et les
veillées des nations unies et il a pu
voir monter au mât le drapeau vert jaune
et rouge à étoile blanche
ainsi s'achève 38 ans de tutelle
française sur l'ancienne colonie
allemande du togo la france pas trônera
la candidature du togo à l'onu et
poursuivra son aide financière au nouvel
état
[Musique]
aucune capitale africaine n'a vécu des
journées de liesse comparable à ces
fêtes qui ont eu lieu à lomé capitale
d'un des plus petits états d'afrique
[Musique]
riche non le président de l' air liquide
monsieur jean de l'orne a présenté à
monsieur janin ministre de l'industrie
la nouvelle centrale au xi leur cette
centrale qui distribue d'oxygène gazeux
à 18 usines par un réseau de 40 km de
canalisation sera le véritable poumon de
la sidérurgie lorraine
l'inde n'est pas le seul en effet avoir
besoin d'oxygène l'industrie moderne en
est une grande consommatrice
hambourg en oxygène par exemple ce canon
d'un nouveau genre qui permet de
nettoyer en un temps record les bêtes
des convertisseurs et l'industrie lui
doit aussi ce brûleur de 6 millions de
calories heures à jet supersonique
enfin des acides très haute qualité sont
obtenus aujourd'hui en france par
insufflation direct d'oxygène pur dans
les tours obtenu à partir de l'air libre
l'oxygène est devenu un gaz vital pour
l'industrie le matin à paris fait
fleurir les collections celle qu'on a
présentée au pavillon d'armenonville
s'adressait aussi bien aux hommes aux
femmes et aux enfants qu'elle se
proposait d'ailleurs de vêtir de pied
tant qu'à du bas aux bonnets du pull aux
sous vêtements
mais là n'était pas sa plus grande
originalité cette collection
traduisaient en effet une révolution
dans la bonneterie
elle réunissait les productions de 28
industries du nord et du pas-de-calais
soit la moitié de la production
bonneterie de ces départements
face au marché commun chaque usine ut
prouver seuls deux grandes difficultés
qu'il s'agisse d'aménager des
fabrications ou de donner une solution
aux problèmes de distribution et
d'exportation en se groupant au
contraire dans un ensemble
chacune d'elles a pu se spécialiser dans
ses meilleures productions en fonction
de son expérience propre
elle bénéficie du même coup de
l'organisation commerciale commune
la solitude n'est plus possible dans
l'organisation économique moderne
l'avenir sans aucun doute est à ceux qui
l'auront les premiers compris
[Musique]
dernière née de l'industrie automobile
française la 404 peugeot a eu les
honneurs de la presse complétant la
gamme des 403 elle est dotée d'un moteur
inclinée à 45 degrés d'une puissance de
9 chevaux fiscaux développement 72
chevaux
côté confort les sièges inclinables
semble devoir satisfaire les plus
délicats
avec cela un coffre d'un demi mètre cube
divise profond sens km et plus de 140 à
l'heure
[Musique]
la reine elizabeth a fait son entrée
entre sa mère et son fils auprès du duc
d'edimbourg la princesse margaret
ravissante visiblement ému a traversé la
neige
[Applaudissements]
anthony armstrong jones enfin l'a
rejointe au pied de l'autel et dans
l'impressionnante abbaye de westminster
le nom était ainsi arrivé qu'attendait
palpitant les coeurs sensibles et l'on
sait qu'ils ne sont pas exclusivement
britannique le moment du jeu le voeu par
lequel margaret princesse d'angleterre
devenait madame armstrong jones
[Musique]
on aime toujours les histoires d'amour
ont les préférait autrefois quand le
prince et puget la bergère cette fois la
princesse épouse le photographe mais
c'est encore un peu la même chose et si
les rois et les princes ont boudé le
mariage de la princesse margaret
tout le peuple de londres lui était là
de westminster à buckingham
la foule pouvait difficilement être plus
dense pour assister au passage du
carrosse qui emmenait les époux
[Applaudissements]
devant le palais la foule s'était
refermée derrière le carrosse et lorsque
monsieur et madame armstrong jones
apparu au balcon
on peut être sûr que bon nombre de
londoniens ont frisé l'est toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cependant le britannia le yacht royal
attendait sur la tamise l'angleterre
avait offert aux jeunes époux un voyage
de noces digne d'un peuple de marins une
croisière sous le soleil des caraïbes
quelques noms encore et monsieur et
madame armstrong jones aller goûter les
joies de l'enfant un seul du moins si
l'on excepte les 237 marins du britannia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]